en este vídeo vamos a sumergirnos en el
mundo de las ecuaciones diferenciales
del segundo orden y yo sé que lo primero
que me van a preguntar es que es una
ecuación diferencial de segundo orden
pues son como ya habíamos visto
ecuaciones diferenciales pero en este
caso vamos a tener inmiscuida a la
segunda derivada en este vídeo vamos a
ver las ecuaciones diferenciales
lineales de segundo orden y esto le va a
servir mucho a las personas que estudian
física clásica vamos a ver
para empezar el caso general supongamos
que tenemos la función a x es decir una
función que depende de x multiplicada
por jerry prima ojo aquí está la segunda
derivada más bx pero esta vez x prima
más c x pero esta vez multiplicado por
la función normal sin ninguna derivada y
esto lo vamos a hacer igual a otra
función igual de x nada de de equis ok
este va a ser mi caso general de todo lo
que voy a resolver a continuación pongan
mucha atención tenemos una segunda
derivada
es decir este segundo orden la ecuación
diferencial y por eso es que se llama
una ecuación diferencial de segundo
orden y quiero hacer notar dos cosas muy
importantes en esta ecuación de segundo
orden la primera es que es lineal es
decir el término x b x cx y de x todos
son términos que dependen solamente de x
es decir no dependen de iu y la segunda
cosa que quiero analizar les es que
lleve prima prima es decir la segunda
derivada de la primera derivada de y son
con respecto a x de hecho quiero ver un
caso esta vez más particular en donde
hay x va a ser solamente una constante
la constante
que va a multiplicar a la segunda
derivada de con respecto a x osea yeví
prima más bx pero esta vez va a ser
solamente una constante que va a
multiplicar a la primera derivada más
cede x pero ésta cede x solamente va a
ser una constante le voy a poner se que
multiplica la función
voy a ser igual a 0 ojo estoy diciendo
que x es cero porque estoy haciendo este
caso pues en primer lugar es un caso
particular y mucho más sencillo de
analizar la segunda razón es que esta
ecuación es una ecuación de tipo
homogénea pues está igualada a cero pero
voy a analizar todo con mucha calma lo
primero que quiero que veamos es que
tenemos una segunda derivada inmiscuida
es decir es una ecuación diferencial de
segundo orden y además la derivada de
más alto orden que tenemos en la
ecuación
otra cosa que quiero que analicemos es
que esta igualdad 0 es decir es una
ecuación del tipo homogéneo y esto ya lo
habíamos visto cuando analizamos
ecuaciones diferenciales de primer orden
aquí también aparecen y es muy
importante que lo analicemos con mucho
cuidado el caso de tipo homogéneo
siempre voy a decir que es una ecuación
homogénea
je ne a exacto cuando esté igualada 0
bien
mi tercer cosa que quiero analizar es
que es una función lineal y es lineal
porque tanto a como b como c son
constantes en este caso es decir no
dependen de x son un numerito como tal
este tipo de ecuaciones son las que
vamos a analizar tanto en este vídeo
como en vídeos posteriores pero lo que
sí les quiero decir es que estas
ecuaciones tienen solución de un modo
muy algebraico y se van a dar cuenta más
adelante y van a ver que realmente la
solución es muy hermosa pero para esto
voy a tratar de cambiar a otro color
esta vez y voy a enseñarles propiedades
muy muy importantes y puedes empezar se
va a ver mejor voy a decir que x es
solución de esta ecuación diferencial
imaginan que ya encontré una solución
que quiere decir eso pues que por mi
prima
porque prima más c por g pues esto es
igual a cero y esto pasa porque que de x
es una solución les digo imagínense que
ya encuentre una solución y esta
solución solamente va a depender
entonces de x ok si pasa esto mi
pregunta va a ser si yo tenemos la
constante c 1 y la multiplicó por qué de
x también en solución para responder
esto voy a cambiar al color café pero
antes de que yo quiero que analicemos
una cosa muy importante si yo tengo c 1
x gdx y lo meto más bien lo derivó dos
veces entonces voy a tener c 1 x heavy
prima de x porque pues la derivada
cumple esa propiedad no es decir voy a
tener a por c 1 porque mi prima
+ b x c 1 porque prima más c por unos
ojos 6 segundos son constantes distintas
por segundo porque y yo quiero ver qué
pasa con con ésta
con esta expresión que yo tengo aquí
para eso pues puedo factorizar el c1 y
constante 1 y voy a tener pues c 1 que
multiplica aa porque mi prima más b
porque prima más c por g pero ya vieron
que encontré como sabíamos que g es una
solución entonces a porque mi prima más
b porque prima más por g esto por
hipótesis ya sabemos que es igual a 0 y
si se dan cuenta se uno por cero pues es
igual a cero por lo que acaba de
demostrar ni más ni menos que cuando yo
tengo una constante multiplicada por mi
solución y lo meto de ecuación
diferencial del segundo orden pues esto
mi constante por mi solución es decir
sea uno por gd x también es solución ok
y esto para que lo voy a ocupar ahorita
van a ver quieras demostrar antes una
segunda propiedad
esta segunda propiedad también va a ser
muy importante para que nosotros
encontremos la solución general
demi ecuación homogénea ok entonces
tomemos a hdx como otra solución aparte
de gx que también cumpla la ecuación
homogénea bien qué va a pasar ahora con
gdx + hdx lo que quiero saber es si la
suma de mis soluciones también es
solución de una ecuación diferencial
bueno para probar esto quiero recordar
que la derivada de las sumas de otras
funciones pues es la suma de las
derivadas de las funciones utilizando
esto que les acabamos de decir y
sustituyendo en ecuación me va a quedar
a que va a multiplicar a la segunda
derivada de g + h o sea que mi prima más
a chevy prima y de manera análoga pues
me va a quedar p que va a multiplicar a
la primera derivada de gemma sachs o sea
que prima más h prima más c que va a
multiplicar pues a mis funciones sin
ninguna derivada o sea que más h
y bueno yo no sé qué pasa con esto pero
lo que sí puede hacer es distribuirla
multiplicando aa porque mi prima ya a
por hb prima también lo mismo para la
vez
p porque prima más p por h prima muy
bien y también para la se me va a
quedarse porque más ser por h
bueno estoy distribuyendo todo esto
porque ahora voy a juntar términos
semejantes
miren voy agarra todo lo que tenga que
ver con que me va a quedar a por heavy
prima más ve porque prima más c por g y
a todo esto pues le voy a sumar a lo que
me resta con la h o se me va a quedar a
por aquí mi prima más b por h prima
+ h ok pero bien vamos a observar todo
lo que tenemos aquí
yo se queje de x por hipótesis es la
solución y hdx polvo tesistán viene la
solución entonces todo esto que está
aquí cumple la ecuación diferencia en el
segundo orden homogénea es decir todo
esto es cero y como hd también de la
solución pues también todo esto cero y
si yo sumo 0 +0 pues también es cero es
decir acabo de probar que exige y h son
ambas soluciones entonces la suma de
ellas también es solución de una
ecuación diferencial y de hecho lo puedo
ver de una manera mucho más general por
qué pues porque yo ya probé la propiedad
1 y la propiedad está 2 es decir yo
puedo decir que sí tengo una constante
le voy a escribir acá si tengo una
constante de uno que multiplica
gx y yo tengo otra constante c2 que
multiplica hdx pues esto también es
solución de mi ecuación diferencial la
homogénea que padre está esto no aunque
también es importante hacer notar que c1
y c2 no tienen por qué no ser cero puede
ser que ese 1 o c2 pues sean 0 en fin
estas propiedades que vamos a probar nos
van a servir para encontrar la solución
general de la ecuación diferencial de
segundo orden homogéneo pero eso ya lo
veremos en vídeos posteriores ya verán
que esto es mucho más fácil de lo que
pensamos de hecho este león no es como
lo pintan pero eso ya lo veremos en
nuestro siguiente vídeo